[Música]
ricardo flores conoció el hip hop y el
rap en las calles de lima y en el año
2015 se convirtió en libera tocan y el
rapero en quechua desde el campo a la
ciudad de la ciudad al campo sin
distinción de donde vengas no entonces
la música ahí viene dónde viene la
música rompe con barreras rompe con todo
eso lo que se piensa de que hay no el
que hecho solamente para cantarlo o para
hablarlo en el campo pero no con esta
música y está en una propuesta que
traigo pues trató de eliminar todo eso
tiró wang y me importa del campo la
ciudad la ciudad el campo el escrito
donde sea
[Música]
en sus canciones el quechua de sus
ancestros se amolda en armonía con los
ritmos modernos
[Música]
porque hecho como cualquier otro idioma
tiene esa fuerza para poder transmitir
lo que uno siente y el quechua es un
idioma de guerra es un idioma guerrero
es un idioma de lucha es un idioma
poético es un idioma dulce es un idioma
que en realidad que uno puede expresar
se como quiera con el quechua y su
música lo ha llevado por alemania españa
a estados unidos y parte de américa
latina
liberato ha grabado dos álbumes y tiene
previsto producir más videoclips
la pandemia del cobi 19 lo obligó a
parar pero el próximo año volverá a
europa con su álbum pahua spy
los andes del perú conservan las
costumbres de los incas aquí sobrevive
la ancestral lengua materna que en las
grandes ciudades muchos peruanos tratan
de olvidar así a guaminí yo vi cómo
mataban quispe y ataja para muchos para
renata flores ha estado unida al que ha
hecho ahí la música desde el vientre de
su madre su bisabuelo y sus padres son
músicos por eso no le fue difícil
comenzar a componer a los 16 años
funcionar el rap trap músicos música
urbana con el quechua es algo que a mí
me gusta muchísimo esos géneros
y pues el entorno también no hizo que
pueda escuchar y ser como
empezar a buscar esa identidad que hay
dos mundos no que es el quechua el mundo
de nuestros ancestros de las costumbres
nuestra cultura y también por otro lado
él
lo urbano el pop y todo eso
creo que soy yo y es lo que quería
mostrar en mi música
a sus 20 años renata flores es una de
las voces jóvenes de esta nueva
corriente inspirada en la revalorización
de la lengua de los pueblos originarios
del perú sus canciones le han permitido
presentarse en italia y eeuu jugaron
villaguay
[Música]
emprendimiento musical motivó a que el
medio estadounidense the new york times
la bauticé como la reina peruana del rap
en que china
pero su arte no sólo contempla ritmos y
melodías también transmite mensajes que
reivindican las mujeres y los
feminicidios que este problema pasa en
todos en todos lados no en la sierra en
ayacucho en lima en el extranjero en
todos lados y esto es algo que quería
mostrar en quechua no para dar un
mensaje a las mujeres que no callemos
que debemos estar unidas no en que tú
aún mejor no que otras personas que son
queso hablantes escuchan este mensaje es
muy importante no ahora como la música
es un idioma universal
lo podemos entender hacer como un ensayo
pero los productores musicales saben que
la interculturalidad peruana se puede
mezclar con instrumentos clásicos y
aseguran que también se amoldan
perfectamente con los beats electrónicos
jose rodriguez ha producido el disco
remezcla p considera que la fusión es
una buena oportunidad para abrir caminos
a la industria musical peruana yo creo
que ya nos toca ya toca que el que el
perú sea empieza a ser visto como una
común
como un país como un lugar que empieza a
exportar música música que tiene que
tiene
identidad y que tiene este que tiene
cuerpo y cara peruana este yo creo que
ya nos toca y hay muchos trabajos muchos
artistas que ahora están trabajando en
verdad de una manera esté bastante
profesional y yo creo que yo como digo
lo lo veo bien de una manera positiva
pero es un país de un rico pasado
cultural una inspiración con múltiples
historias para los músicos de este país
quienes quieren brindarle un nuevo ritmo
al mundo
[Música]